As I mentioned earlier, Quicksilver was done in
the early 80s, and here is a sketch reproduced
from their paper. An interesting thing that you
notice is that this sketch is very similar to
what I showed you as the current structure
of network operating systems in the earlier panel. It's
a microkernel based design and Quicksilver was the
same vintage as Mach from CMU. And having seen
the structure of operating systems in
earlier lessons, this picture should be very
familiar to you, that all the system
services are provided above the microkernel. And
the microkernel is only responsible for Process
Management, IPC, and Machine Control, and all
of the system services such as Window
Manager, File System, Virtual Memory, and Communication,
all of them sit above the microkernel,
and the system services are implemented as
server processes. Now, the late 80's was
exciting time for distributed systems. There were no
laptops in that time. We were moving
from CRT terminals, Cathode Ray Terminals, connected to
mainframe to the era of office workstations,
what we routinely call as desktops these days.
Quicksilver was conceived as a workstation operating
system. And the ideas that are enshrined
in the Quicksilver operating system predates over
concurrent with many things that we take for
granted today, such as network file system,
remote procedure call, the Internet, the World Wide
Web, and so on. What sets Quicksilver
apart from the competition at that time when
new services such as window manager for managing the real estate on the
workstation screen and how it should be
integrated into the operating system as a
whole? Services that may not be available
in the workstation itself, for example, a
file server maybe remote. So integrating communication
into the design of the operating system
was key and services that are within a workstation and across workstation
on the network in the distributed system need to recover from failures. Rather
than ad hoc mechanism for each server to recover from such failures, Quicksilver
was the first to propose transaction
as a unifying concept for recovery management
of the servers. It was the first
operating system to propose transactions in operating systems
and that's the reason you see transaction manager
as part of the service provided by the
operating system. A quick personal note, I
was a graduate student at University of Wisconsin,
Madison in the early '80s, and spent a
year in IBM research working with the group
that conceived and designed this Quicksilver operating
system. My dissertation research, which was on
hardware support for inter process communication, used
as an experimental platform, a precursor to
the Quicksilver operating system which is called
925. Recall what I told you earlier
that Quicksilver was intended as a workstation
operating system, and 925 was the name
of the operating system that was a precursor to Quicksilver.
And as you can imagine this is a pun on
office workstation nine to five. That was the name given
to internally to the precursor of the Quicksilver operating system.